récemment des scientifiques ont encoder
sur une molécule d adn synthétique de
des documents les plus précieux de
l'histoire de france cela pourrait mener
éventuellement à la création d'une
puissante technologies capables
d'archiver d'innombrables donné
au creux de la main une capsule
métallique que peut-elle contenir elle
renferme de l'information
beaucoup d'informations de quoi remplir
des milliards de bibliothèque bienvenue
dans l'univers de l'archivage
moléculaire une solution au problème de
stockage de données
les supports numériques actuels posent
de nombreux problèmes et en particulier
ils ont un impact une empreinte
environnementale qui est catastrophique
considère qu'aujourd'hui on peut stocker
30% de l'information congénères et d'ici
dix ans ce sera 3 % et avec l'explosion
de l'intelligence artificielle des
objets connectés on a besoin de stocker
de plus en plus de données et nos
supports actuels ne pourront pas faire
ça donc il est urgent de remplacer ces
supports fragile encombrants énergivores
par des nouveaux supports
le support dont il parle n'est pas si
nouveau en fait il existe depuis 4
milliards d'années ce support c'est
l'adn la molécule qui porte les
instructions génétiques de la vie on
s'en inspire pour créer un outil
d'archivage
c'est une forme de stockage ultra denses
des millions de fois plus dense que les
supports numériques actuels ça veut dire
qu'on pourrait faire tenir l'intégralité
des données numériques du monde de tous
les disques durs de tous les data center
du monde dans 100 g la ds c'est à dire
l'équivalent du volume d'une tablette de
chocolat
paris france archives nationales
lieu du savoir absolu l'espace est
magnifique les étagères remplies du
savoir humain mis côte à côte les
volumes s'étire sur 375 km
[Musique]
les documents les plus précieux de
l'histoire de france sont conservés ici
derrière cette porte
[Musique]
à l'automne 2000 21 2 capsules en acier
inoxydable ont été ajoutées à l'armoire
de faire une première on a décidé d'en
codée sur adn deux textes historiques
français la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen de 1789 et la
déclaration des droits de la femme et de
la citoyenne qui un texte de mon
institutionnels rédigée par olympe de
gouges en 1791
grâce à l'informatique
aujourd'hui on numérise tout par exemple
la déclaration a été encodée sous la
forme de 0 et de 1 pour la transposer
sur l'adn on utilise la même série de
chiffres qu'on converti en lettres
on prend les lettres à ct kg qui
correspondent à l'alphabet des
généticiens
un robot produits chimiques mans une
paire de lettres à la fois ont créé de
petits fragments qu'on assemble ensuite
pour former une longue molécule d'adé n
synthétique
c'est un stockage du moléculaire donc
c'est une molécule vous pouvez pas
l'avoir à l'oeil nu un scellé c'est lors
du du nanomètre c'est une molécule qui
est hyper stable exactement comme un
polymère de plastique sûr que c'est un
polymère de l'adn mais mais c'est une
molécule qui qui qui est ultra
résistante et qui ne présentent aucun
risque de cassure ans à chaque fois
qu'on accorde un document ont produit
une nouvelle molécule d'adr
même si cet adn synthétique
la méthode soulève une question
en encodant un dictionnaire par exemple
ne risque-t-on pas de créer une nouvelle
forme de vie
comme on manipule de l'adn etc la dnl
supports de l'information génétique il
faut être vigilant ne pas encordé
n'importe quelle séquence pour que par
hasard une séquence qui correspond à une
vidéo la succession des lettres concode
correspondent à une molécule qui
pourrait être dangereuse comme une
toxine par exemple qui pourrait être
dangereux soit pour l'être humain soit
pour l'environnement on le fait pas au
hasard on le fait avec un algorithme
spécifique qui enlève tous les les les
informations qui permettent aux vivants
de coder de l'information est donc cet
adn est ce que nous on appelle bio
sécurisé c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne le code
offre aucune information biologique mais
par contre il code de l'information
numérique
[Musique]
les capsules métalliques entreposés aux
archives nationales contiennent chacune
100 milliards de copies comment peut-on
produire autant de copies
une fois qu'on obtient ces molécules ont
les introduit dans des bactéries on les
multiplie ces bactéries pour obtenir des
milliards de copies de ces molécules
l'adn ont ensuite extrait ces molécules
l'adn on les poulets ont les purifie on
les lyophilisée on les stocke dans les
petites capsules métalliques
car la bactérie se divise elle transfère
son adn à la suivante par photocopieurs
vivant mais lorsque la bactérie se
réplique des erreurs de transcription
sont possibles et bien sûr les copies ne
sont pas parfaites il ya un certain taux
d'erreur mais ce n'est pas une seule
bactérie ou un seul organisme qui va
multiplier ces copies mais un très grand
nombre et donc les 100 milliards de
copies peut-être il ya quelques copies
qui auront des mutations mêler les
autres n'en n'auront pas et donc on
pourra toujours relire l'information
parce que la majorité des molécules
n'auront pas la même mutation
dans la bibliothèque du futur commencera
consulter un document archivé de la
sorte d'abord il faudra réhydrater la
molécule synthétique pour la déposer
dans un lecteur à adn on utilise des
séquenceurs l'adn c'est à dire les mêmes
séquences heures que ceux qui sont
utilisés pour séquencé les génomes des
êtres vivants où les variants du
coronavirus donc on utilise ces
séquences heures pour relire la
succession des lettres à cette ag qui
sont dans notre molécule d adn et
ensuite on fait la reconversion en
données binaires 0 et 1 bien qu'elle
soit spectaculaire la technologie n'est
pas encore à point l'encodage prend
plusieurs jours et le décodage plusieurs
heures pour ces raisons l'adn ne
convient qu'à certains types de
documents
un très grand nombre de données dans le
monde sont des données qu'on appelle
froide ou ultra froide c'est à dire des
données qui sont pas en ligne qui sont
pas accessibles facilement mais qu'on
souhaite conserver mais auquel on n'a
pas besoin d'accéder dans l'immédiat on
n'a pas forcément besoin d'avoir accès à
tous ces documents à la
très rapidement mais on veut être sûr
qu'on pourra si nécessaire accéder à ce
document un jour
pour un archiviste l'adn est ni plus ni
moins le support idéal
quand on stocke sur l'adn l'adn dans les
petites capsules que nous n'utilisons
lestat pour cinquante mille ans sans
aucun apport d'énergie et on pourra
toujours leur lire parce que le vivant
va pas changer le support de
l'information génétique on aura toujours
besoin de relire l'adn parce que la vie
sera toujours basé sur l'adn on aura
toujours besoin pour la médecine et pour
la pour la recherche biologique donc
c'est un support qui sera jamais
obsolescence et que c'est le graal pour
les archivistes
bien qu'il s'agisse d'un support
d'avenir jamais une étagère de capsules
d'athènes ne remplacera le plaisir
d'humer l'odeur du papier de feuilleter
un livre bref d'étirer le temps aux
archives nationales
[Musique]